in Ostdeutschland auch in Thüringen ganz
besonders in Sachsen aber eben auch in
Thüringen hat die CDU Desaster erlebt
hat ja wir haben gestern die
wahlkreiskarte gesehen Sachsen vor allem
aber eben auch Thüringen sind blau
geworden und blau bedeutet AFD trägt
Armin Laschet die Schuld daran
die Schuld trägt die Gesamtpartei die
CDU hatte im Osten nicht die Themen
angesprochen die die Sorgen der Leute
sind das muss auch aufgearbeitet werden
das ist ein katastrophales Ergebnis und
am Ende sind viele Gründe und sicherlich
ist es auch eine Frage des
Spitzenkandidaten aber es ist eine
Gesamtpartei die hier Verantwortung
treten dass die Union
eine Gesamtpartei aber dennoch war Armin
Laschet der falsche Kandidat um die
Wähler im Osten abzuholen
es wird ernsthafter Weise niemand
bezweifeln dass der Spitzenkandidat
jetzt im Osten keinen Zug fährt gewesen
ist aber besonders auch das Thema Corona
hat spätestens seit der bundesnotbremse
zu massiven verärgerungen in der
Wählerschaft geführt es ging auch um die
Frage hat der Osten im Wahlkampf
überhaupt eine Rolle gespielt da haben
sich viele gewundert dass da über die
Köpfe hinweg gesprochen worden ist und
am Ende merkt man eben auch dass
vielfach so diese Berlin-Mitte Themen
hier im ländlichen Raum nicht so richtig
angekommen sind die Wähler die die Union
wählen die erwarten ja dass ihr kleiner
Wohlstand gesichert wird und diese
Themen haben wir gar nicht angesprochen
man kann es nicht anders sagen wer die
Dörfer und die kleinen Städte verliert
verliert am Ende auch das Land also
Armin Laschet hat auch auf diese
Berlin-Mitte Themen gesetzt was sind
denn diese Berlin-Mitte Themen
naja es ist eine immer eine Frage in
Vordergrund zu stellen ja Klimawandel
die Frage dass das natürlich teuer wird
für die Leute nur wissen Sie wenn wir
mittlerweile bei Benzinpreisen bald auf
zwei Euro zu steuern und wir Leute in
Thüringen haben die beide auf ihr Auto
angewiesen sind dann kostet das
natürlich normale Familien oder wenn es
um die Frage geht von Digitalisierung
auch im ländlichen Raum als die Menschen
das Gefühl dass sie abgehangen werden
und das hat im Osten eine große Rolle
gespielt weil sie mir das Gefühl hatten
es wird über ihre Köpfe hinweg
Lebensstil propagiert werden ihre ist
mit welchen Themen hätte man im Osten
punkten müssen ganz zwingend in diesem
Wahlkampf
ich glaube im Vordergrund hätte erstmal
bezahlbares Leben stehen müssen nämlich
die Frage was an Belastung mittlerweile
für auf die Leute zukommt ihnen wurde
die Ölheizung genommen die ganzen
Rohstoffpreisen teurer geworden die
Handwerker
ächzen unter der Frage was das Benzin
für sie kostet was für Bürokratiekosten
für sie letztlich auch
unterwegs sind das sind alles Themen die
im Vordergrund gestanden hätten aber vor
allen Dingen lebensnaht eben greifbares
wir haben plakatiert wir wollen den
Klima neutrales Industrieland sein diese
innere Anspruch ist richtig aber was
dahinter sich verbirgt für die Menschen
war einfach nicht greifbar war nicht
empathisch und ich denke das ist etwas
was durchaus auch eine Rolle gespielt
hat in diesem Wahlkampf und andere
Themen wären logischerweise auch gewesen
rentengerechtigkeit Lohngerechtigkeit
wir sind im 30 Jahr der deutschen
Einheit
noch darüber hinaus und trotzdem haben
wir unterschiedliche Löhne das können
sie ja niemanden mehr erklären und das
ist auch ein Thema was eine CDU als
Partei der Einheit adressieren muss
nochmal zurück zur Armin Laschet da
waren die Umfragen ja schon vor der Wahl
was ich den wollten die deutschen
eindeutig nicht zum Kanzler haben die
überwiegende Mehrheit nicht genauso war
das Ergebnis auch genauso auch die
nachwahlbefragung die Umfragen danach es
war ganz klar die Deutschen wollten
diesen Mann nicht der hat nicht gezogen
sollte Armin Laschet jetzt die Union
weiter in die Zukunft führen
ich halte nichts davon dass man
irgendwie immer so einzelne Leute
rausgreift und sie Partei gewinnt
zusammen sie verliert zusammen klar ist
dass er im Wahlkampf jetzt nicht das Zug
fährt im Osten gewesen ist na das habe
ich schon gesagt der Vogt ich habe nur
den Mann rausgegriffen den sie
überlebensgroß auf die Plakate gedruckt
haben das ist ja schon entscheidend
dessen Kopf da drauf ist und die
Menschen wollten ihn nicht deswegen ist
es doch für sie eine existenzielle Frage
wen sie danach vorne stellen wer ihre
Nummer eins ist das ist nicht irgendwer
den man sich da rauspickt sondern der
Mann der wie gesagt über lebensgroß
überall in den Städten zu sehen war
zumindest auf der Zielgeraden ja
zumindest halten wir jetzt erstmal als
Partei entschieden dass er die Gespräche
auch notwendigerweise führen soll ich
sehe uns nicht im Lied weil wir sind
nicht Nummer eins aber wenn es so kommt
dass eben auch Grüne und FDP
Gesprächsbereitschaft signalisieren dann
sollte das auch passieren und ich glaube
für diese Gespräche hat Armin Laschet
jetzt erstmal ein Auftrag und was wir
als Partei schonungslos analysieren
müssen das steht jetzt an und für mich
steht Vordergrund eine neue Basis
Verbundenheit das darf nicht einfach nur
eine Analyse im Bundesvorstand sein
sondern müssen alle Mitglieder
mitgenommen werden und für uns im Osten
gilt wir brauchen ostkonferenz wo alle
ostdeutschen Landesverbände
zusammenkommen und genau auch diesen
Druck auf die Bundespartei ausüben
gehen
[Musik]